Based on this data, they make
a preliminary diagnosis if possible, and
order laboratory imaging and
other tests to obtain as much
objective data as possible.
>From this aggregated database of
subjective information from the patient
and objective data from their own
observations and their tests and images,
they assign the patient with one or
more diagnoses, and develop a plan for
managing them that usually
involves prescribing medications.
In subsequent visits,
they follow up and make adjustments.
The treatment plan may involve
referral to specialists,
requiring coordination with providers
working at different care venues, and
possibly in different communities and
health systems.